so how did your fans handle cuz I am a  fan of Medea like and I'm gonna keep my  thoughts to myself Tyler but how did  everybody else handle the Diaz passing  is it over first of all she I've been  wrestling with that overwrought man  she's trying to come out no no no it's  not it's it's that I did the farewell  tour the last tour that I did just to  say thank you to all the fans was  amazing we sold out all over the country  I it's been a great run and if she has  something to say who knows she'll show  up  I have I have bt+ now which is a  streaming service so maybe that's what  she'll be I will not stop talking until  you subscribe to my youtube channel  that's right and I could talk a lot  seriously not gonna stop yep still here  not going anywhere I see you don't walk  away from this